americans are getting more comfortable  flying again during the pandemic but  that means more problems at airports  across the country  airlines are trying to make up for lost  time and revenue by selling more tickets  and  opening more seats all that comes with  some new advice for passengers  be prepared airlines say more  cancellations are possible as they just  try and get up to speed  they're evaluating flight schedules and  patterns  daily now because so many people are  booking and we just  didn't expect this sudden surge  industry experts like the woman you just  heard from say some airlines need to  recall laid off crew members  and some pilots will have to be  re-qualified before they can get back in  the air